foreign choose a random street in a
random neighborhood on a random day in
Toronto and odds are the first person
you see not including tourists won't
have been born in Canada
51 or 1.4 of its 2.7 million residents
are immigrants significantly more than
Los Angeles San Francisco or even New
York
last year Canada welcomed 437 thousand
new permanent residents one percent of
its entire national population
when you count all new residents
permanent and not the nation grew by 2.7
percent making it the 16th fastest
growing country in the world and the
only one of these not in Africa or Asia
and yet Canada is just getting started
13 years from now immigrants are
expected to make up 30 percent of the
population compared to 23 percent today
now compare that to The Melting Pot
known as the United States of America
when you ask Americans how many
immigrants they think are in the country
the average answer is 40 percent
in fact every demographic group white
black Latino Asian liberal conservative
even immigrants themselves vastly
overestimates the true number just 14
percent
here's a list of the 34 countries and
territories with a larger share of
immigrants per capita than the US
after removing small countries those
with a population under 10 million you
can see what actually sets America apart
its size
the United States is the largest country
that accepts a significant share of
immigrants
but as a share of the population Canada
far more than America is truly a nation
of immigrants
even more striking is the large number
of young Engineers doctors and
scientists settling in Canada over the
United States
nearly the same number of documented
employment-based immigrants entered
Canada as the U.S in 2022 despite being
only one-tenth as large
no offense to our exceptionally friendly
Northern neighbors but why
the simple answer is that immigrating to
the United States is an insanely
difficult stressful costly lengthy and
arbitrary process while immigrating to
Canada isn't
to see how let's compare the journeys of
two hypothetical immigrants
Sanjay and Rohan were both born in India
they both scored in the 95th percentile
on their college entrance exams and they
both received scholarships to study
abroad Sanjay to Colombia in New York
and Rohan to McGill in Montreal
after graduating Rohan is allowed to
work in Canada for three additional
years Sanjay one year bought three with
a stem major
so far so good but then the paths of our
two immigrants rapidly begin to diverge
assuming Sanjay doesn't have a million
dollars to invest or a close U.S citizen
relative he'll be thrown into the
grueling H-1B gauntlet
the H-1B is a high skill visa for
in-demand specialty occupations like
programmers and accountants
to try for one Sanjay will need to find
an employer who agrees to pay him no
less than the prevailing wage for that
job and to sponsor his application
but that alone is no guarantee far from
it
for the last 20 years Congress has
limited the number of h-1bs to 65 000
per year with an additional 20 000 for
those with Advanced degrees
and in every one of those years
typically in less than five days more
than the maximum 85 000 people have
applied
Sanjay therefore will have to play the
lottery
despite attending one of America's best
schools receiving a perfect GPA
mastering English and acclimating well
his name will be thrown along with
thousands of others into a random number
generator
at this point you'll likely lose and be
kicked back to square one
in a good year 43 percent of applicants
are selected in a bad one like last year
just 14.6 percent the Department of
Homeland Security attributes this to a
rise in fraud
after educating Sanjay for years America
will unintentionally gift his valuable
knowledge and labor to another country
at the exact moment he's ready to
contribute to the U.S economy he'll be
forced to either leave or go back to
school and delay his employment
but let's assume he's one of the lucky
few
having been selected U.S citizenship and
immigration services will look for the
first time at his application
if he's then approved Sanjay will join
the tiny Elite circle of America's most
fortunate immigrants in 2021 the median
wage for all U.S workers was forty five
thousand dollars for H-1B holders it was
108 thousand
even many of the lowest paid H-1B
holders make more than 75 percent of all
Americans
if he chooses to Sanjay will live a life
of abundance
he'll drive a nice car live in a big
house and eat at nice restaurants
but although he'll be financially
comfortable legally he'll exist in a
Perpetual state of anxious precarity
that's because the H-1B is not a green
card it's a temporary work visa
for one this means travel is more
complex leaving the country even for a
few days requires permission
and though unlikely Sanjay will only be
one irritable Border guard away from
being locked out of the place he spent
most of a decade building a life in
[Music]
secondly Sanjay doesn't have permission
to work he has permission to work for a
specific employer
if he's fired or laid off he'll have 60
harrowing days to find a new company
willing to sponsor his Visa or else pack
up and along with his family leave the
country
now to escape this absurdity Sanjay
needs a green card and in theory he's
already eligible to apply
but only his employer can apply on his
behalf
in other words the freedom to leave
one's employer must in most cases be
approved by that very employer
this process is not cheap and only his
company is allowed to pay
so unless Sanjay's skills are truly
Irreplaceable or his employer unusually
generous he may have to wait
after three more years he'll need to
renew his H-1B which can only be done
once and since 2004 requires for no
clear reason traveling back to your home
country's U.S consulate and re-entering
if Sanjay hasn't found an employer
willing to sponsor his green card after
another three years he'll be forced to
leave
but again let's assume he's lucky
after finding a sponsor proving he won't
negatively impact the wages of U.S
workers and that there are no other
qualified candidates Sanjay will finally
start waiting
because not only does Congress limit the
number of green cards it also sets a
limit per country and that number is the
same regardless of its population
1.4 billion people live in India 5
million in Norway but the two countries
have the same annual limit
naturally more Indians and Chinese apply
than Norwegians which creates a backlog
of the former
as of July 2023 these are the priority
dates for this type of green card what
this means is that Indians who applied
on the 1st of January 2009 are just now
receiving their green cards
across all nationalities and all
categories these are the average wait
times to receive one as of 2018.
22 percent weighted between 10 and 19
years five percent waited 20 years or
more
in the meantime Sanjay will be stuck in
limbo a temporary worker tied to a
single employer potentially for decades
during this time he may watch as someone
from a smaller country enters the U.S
for the first time receives a green card
and then even citizenship
now back to Rohan
because he's worked in Canada Rohan is
eligible to apply for Express entry
it's unlike the H-1B Lottery is
transparent and predictable it's based
on a point system
anyone can go online right now enter
things like your English proficiency
work experience and age and immediately
see your score it takes about two
minutes
every few weeks the government invites
everyone with a certain score to apply
previous cutoffs are listed clearly on
the website
if Rohan has a job offer in Canada he'll
very likely be approved
after that not only will he not be tied
to a specific employer but he won't
receive a work visa at all he'll receive
permanent residency
and because Canada has no discriminatory
per country limit you'll receive it
immediately and be treated the same as
anyone from Norway Nigeria or Nepal
in other words Rohan and his family will
live with a degree of security and
stability that Sanjay may not achieve
for another decade or longer
and that's assuming Sanjay won the
lottery and only has to wait a very
optimistic four years for a green card
when viewed this way it's really not
surprising that so many high skill
workers immigrate to Canada
what's surprising is that despite this
kafka-esque bureaucracy many still
prefer America
on this the data is pretty unambiguous
in a 2021 Gallup survey of the 900
million people worldwide who wish to
immigrate nearly 20 said the United
States was their first choice
destination far more than any other
country
and among high-skilled immigrants that
number is likely much higher
the number one reason is money
most H-1B jobs are business science
engineering or computer related
and to be frank Canadian Tech salaries
aren't laughable by comparison
we're talking less than half the money
for the same experience with the same
responsibilities and title
an L5 software developer at Canada's
Shopify makes something in the area of
121 000 US dollars
an L4 at Google makes 264 thousand
dollars and an L5 367 thousand dollars
the higher you go on the org charts the
larger the gap between us and Canadian
wages
the most well-compensated software
engineers at Facebook Google and apple
make one to two million dollars a year
those at Shopify make something like 15
to 30 percent as much
for this reason alone a shocking number
of graduates from Canada's top
universities pack up and move South at
the first opportunity
then you have Canadian housing
an entire video should be devoted to
this topic but for now this graph should
do the trick
this is the growth in U.S income since
2005.
and this is the growth in U.S housing
prices
alright now here are Canadian incomes
and Canadian housing
no one has ever called San Francisco an
affordable place to live but Toronto and
Vancouver aren't much better yet their
salaries are dramatically lower
in 2021 nearly half of new immigrants to
Canada settled in Ontario and of them
the vast majority in one city Toronto
that's a problem because the average
selling price of a home across the whole
province of Ontario is 928 thousand
dollars in British Columbia over a
million
in other words housing prices provide
immigrants with plenty of reasons not to
settle in Canada and high salaries
plenty of reasons to settle in the
United States they just can't
America's current immigration policies
were mostly set in 1990 when just 15
percent of households had a personal
computer
this was a time when virtually none of
the current H-1B jobs even existed
whatever flavor of Reform you prefer
were clearly past due for an update
and until that day comes Canada is very
happily filling this Gap in the market
just this year for instance it announced
a new plan to allow H-1B workers to move
to Canada where they'd be immediately
Unshackled from their employer
this strategy of leveraging its
proximity to and similarities with the
United States only works because the
American Immigration system is so
unbelievably broken
Canada need not address its severe
housing crisis or do the difficult work
of nurturing a Silicon Valley of the
North
whenever a Harvard graduate loses the
H-1B lottery or an Indian national is
stuck waiting a decade or longer for a
Green Card Canada need only do what
America won't let them in
now some may argue that American
Immigration isn't broken so much as it
has chosen different priorities
in 2021 60 of new permanent residents in
America were sponsored by family and 26
by their employer
in Canada these two categories are
almost perfectly reversed
there twenty percent were family based
and 62 percent for employment
it may appear that America's goal is to
unite families while Canada aims first
and foremost to strengthen its economy
but what these numbers hide is the scale
of each country's immigrant population
true a smaller share of new Canadian
immigrants are joining their families
but only because Canada welcomes so many
immigrants in total
in fact per capita it has more
family-sponsored permanent residents
than the US
the same is true of humanitarian
immigrants
Canada admits nearly twice as many
refugees per capita
it isn't pro-wealthy immigrants to the
exclusion of others by most measures its
pro-immigrant full stop
today for example nearly 70 percent
disagree that immigration levels are too
high
perhaps even more surprisingly a
majority in all three of its largest
political parties support immigration
these surveys suggest the country has
cultivated support for a Multicultural
Society as much as a mere willingness to
tolerate newcomers when economically
convenient
speaking of convenience today's sponsor
Trade coffee delivers you a fast fresh
and diverse palette of coffee right to
your doorstep
you'll answer a few quick questions
about your preferences whether you're a
coffee expert or a beginner trade will
find the perfect fit for you from over
450 selections across the country from
dark Rose to Espresso Blends and more
next within 48 Hours of roasting your
personalized coffee will be shipped to
your home for maximum freshness I just
received this great looking Seattle
French roast and before that a
huckleberry dark roast from Denver right
now you can get a free bag of coffee
with any subscription by clicking the
link on screen or in the description
below that's drinktree.com
polymatter thanks to trade for
sponsoring this video
foreign
[Music]